Okay, and the solution is like so. Gets is pretty simple.
First we just call normal get on the cache, and if
there was a value, return that value plus hash repr v
which will just return a nice hash to the value for us.
Now, here's the cas function. First we call gets. And if
the value is actually in the cache. We have our value in
our unique and then we compare the unique we got from
our cache to the unique that was passed in and if they
match, we call set and we return the value of
set which in our case always returns true. Otherwise, we return
false. Simple enough. Let's go ahead and give this a test.
Okay, first off I'm going to run the basic functions. No, it
should print through one, none, none and then a [UNKNOWN] of
two and our hash which in this case is this number
here and then it should print false. Because we tried to
overwrite x with the value three giving it the wrong hash.
In this case zero. And now that we have our hash.
Let's go ahead and paste that into here and see if
these next two statements run. Okay, so I click run again
and we can see that we're printing all the original command still
run, the hash is still the same. This cas command here,
set x to three, with cache val, cache unique value zero,
prints false. Because unique doesn't match, what it, what the unique
should be is this value here. And when we try to set
x to four we see true. And we get x we can see that it was probably set
to four. So that's how gets in cas works.
They are built in the mem cache, you won't ever
have to implement them but now that you know
how they work. You'll be able to use them
in production that much better. And you have another
tool in your toolbox for dealing with complicated caching issues.